dr laura harlock is coming off a 10-day
stretch inside the icu at this toronto
hospital where one-third of its 37 beds
with ventilators are occupied by covid
patients we're still getting kovid
admissions or people with covet who need
our help
it's slowing in terms of the rate a
little bit the latest hospitalization
numbers from ontario and quebec are
trending downward but as the provinces
reopened there's concern the dip may not
last we could face potentially in march
a peak which is even higher that's what
we need to avoid that's not what anyone
wants to hear with frustrations growing
over covered restrictions and lockdowns
as we watch other countries like the uk
and denmark open up you can look at what
other countries are doing but please
don't just follow blindly what every
other country is doing although the
majority almost 78 percent of canadians
are fully vaccinated booster uptake is
still less than half and our health care
systems continue to struggle hospitals
and care clinics are extremely short
staffed and workers are exhausted from
yet another wave and in the west
hospitalizations are still rising
manitoba and bc with record numbers this
week we can't look at it linearly
we have to look at it all together
what's happening we have multiple
indicators that the peak virus load was
earlier in january
we know that hospitalizations follow
that health officials also warn omicron
won't likely be the end of covid harluch
knows it's almost a certainty more
variants will emerge and worries we
continue to be reactive versus proactive
repeating the same mistakes over and
over again is not going to get us
anywhere
wondering how critical care units will
fare
if they have to weather yet another wave
jamie morocco globe